[Musique]
mettez le four à 180° et laisser cuire
35 minutes merci car nc bat recettes de
lasagnes mexicaine ses pairs on n'ose
pas imaginer ce que vous vivez
c'est comme si jeff se faisait renverser
par une voiture et mouret de façon
soudaine et violente
ça fait ça bien ne vous pressez pas pour
nos remarques là
[Musique]
bienvenue chez les amis du paradis nous
avons de nouvelles têtes aujourd'hui je
m'appelle dudit jane j'espère que vous
trouverez pas ça bizarre je veux vous
prendre dans les bras sera pas non
d'accord j'ai perdu mon fiancé il ya
huit semaines
c'est arrivé très vite que ted est mort
je dors plus qui arrivent pas jen s'est
réveillée toute l'année si tu as envie
d'appeler on pourra ne pas dormir
ensemble parce que c'est lui non c'est
mon autre mari attendent à un autre tour
est bien là d'accoucher oui tu habilles
comment je porte des talons de survêt
dit le plus lentement
quoi c'est vraiment bizarre
c
ça t'arrive souvent de faire ça chaque
fois que je vois un pare-chocs défoncé
je me dis qu'il a pu percuter quelqu'un
ça devrait être facile d'être dans sa
grande maison sans steve j'ai une maison
d'hôtes si tu veux on se faire à tous
les jours les garçons je vous présente
je t'ai sailly à paris la fille parce
que le petit oiseau et son père décédé
est que c'est lui d'accord c'est trop
bizarre pour moi que tu sois là non mais
qu'est ce que tu sais même pas qui elle
est c'est peut-être une psychopathe
on vient pour tous du mail qu'elle
voulait vous itunes 10 je dirais que
partout djoudi passe c'est le chaos
[Musique]
tiens je que tu joues avec moi et avec
tous les autres il ya encore tellement
de choses que j'ignore
le chagrin de tous comprendre maintenant
je vous connais vous êtes quelqu'un de
bien cinglé ou pas
vous savez une criminelle dans votre
maison djoudi est la seule qui a été là
pour moi qui ne me donne pas
l'impression d'être en échec dans tous
les domaines on a une veuve en colère
qui joue les chiens de garde
[ __ ] qu'est ce que ce thème toi
[Musique]
je voulais te dire que ok génial je
tente un truc mais vas te [ __ ]